[موسيقى]
صدام حسين الله يرحمه وكل القيادات
العربيه الان يعني مدركين انه هناك تعاون
استراتيجي ما بين امريكا وايران وحتى
اسرائيل
هدفهم يعني كل هاي الدول هدفهم العرب
وهدفهم الامن القومي العربي للموقع
الجيوسياسي للموقع الجيو اقتصادي
بعيده المدى
ايران امريكا اعلنت بالثمانينات احتواء
المزدوج للعراق وايران احتوت العراق ودمرت
العراق اجت في التسعين ولكن لم تعمل شيء
تجاه ايران فكان واضح ومفهوم انه امريكا
حتى يعني
الشرع غزوها لانه من الدوله ما تسمح لها
ما صد القرار فلجئت وين المجلس النواب
الامريكي او الكونغرس الامريكي
بدات تطلع موضوع اسلحه الدمار شامل وموضوع
حلبشه ضرب حلبشه وموضوع اخر الحريات
والديمقراطيه وما الى ذلك
احتل العراق وبحثت
بحثت هذه الجيوش من الفرق عن اسلحه دمار
الشامل لم تجد
[موسيقى]
حتى بالهجوم على الفاو يتهم الامريكيين
بانهم هم من حرضوا الايرانيين على الفور
كانت الاقمار الصناعيه
تستكشف
مواقع القطعات العراقيه
هي الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اعطت ثغره
تصور للقوات العراقيه للقوات الايرانيه ان
هناك ثغره
فالاميرة ايران عندما هجاء هاجمت على
الفاو احتلت الفاو كانت بنصيحه وصور
ومعلومات امريكيه 100%
[موسيقى]